[موسيقى]
هو الفندق الوحيد تحت الماء في العالم ،
لذا يجب أن تكون غواصًا أو تتعلم
كيفية الغوص في دورة تمهيدية
قبل النزول إلى الفندق
فيما يتعلق بالتحديات التي تعرفها
بين الصيف والشتاء التي يمكن أن نواجهها
تغيير بمقدار 20 درجة في
درجة حرارة الماء ، لذا فإن مجرد التعامل مع ذلك
النزول إلى الموطن اليوم
لم يكن أكثر تجربة ممتعة ، فقد
كان الماء باردًا جدًا هذا
الصباح ،
لذا فهذه واحدة من أكبر التحديات التي
يمكن أن يستوعبها الفندق الآن حتى ستة أشخاص.
لها
وجهان مختلفان
ولكن لدينا غرفة مشتركة
حيث نحن الآن هذا هو المطبخ
أه المنطقة مع التلفزيون وما إلى ذلك
، ثم على الجانب الآخر لدينا
منطقة النوم حيث
لدينا منطقة يمكن تقسيمها  مع
سريرين كاملين ثم سريرين بطابقين ، فأنت
تعرف الشيء الكبير الذي
يرسم الابتسامة على وجوه الكثير من الأشخاص
توصيل البيتزا
وكيف نحصل على البيتزا جيدًا ، نستخدم
الصناديق الجافة لدينا
مقاطع فيديو نستخدمها
لإرفاقهم بجزء كبير من الرصاص وأن المشابك
مصممة لتثبيت الصندوق في وضع أفقي ، فإن
كل شخص
أحضرته هنا قد أذهلته
التجربة
والقدرة على
العيش تحت الماء ووسائل الراحة التي
تعال معها